ce soir je voudrais parler avec vous de
déclencheur émotionnel les lie
commençons par jack et vous on peut
peut-être à c'est autre chose
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens ont remarqué que vous
agissez de façon étrange comment ça
étrange
[Musique]
je connais quelqu'un avec qui j'ai
travaillé et qui ne vit pas loin de chez
vous il serait parfait pour vous de
tomari lily un rendez vous mais pas
d'animal c'est une première
des changes et la plupart des meubles de
la maison contre un fauteuil un simili
cuir les différentes étapes du deuil
vous connaissez la troisième c'est celle
du marchandage et de la colère en
qualité tiendrait la dépollution ses
pairs j'ai hâte d'y être désolé mais je
ne m'occupe plus de ce genre de cas
récents vouloir vous manquez de respect
savoir si un jour vous avez un problème
avec un animal vous le savez vous
trouvez
alors ça c'est un lait tourne il est
très territorial
il est tournon sont différents des
autres je veux tu devrais y aller quand
il ce couple ils font leurs nids
ensemble ne sont pas faits pour exister
tout seul dans ce cas
ma femme me laisserai jamais tomber ça
lui traverse pas l'esprit j'aime
tellement ce carnet
je serai plus fort à ses côtés
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on est bon qu'est ce que c'est
ma mère m'en mettait toujours pour le
déjeuner deux boules de coco pour les
pick up
et jack cela lui des coui c'est bien et
voilà c'est une bonne question vous êtes
sont six mais qui se cache sous avait
tout
je fais une dépression c'est pour ça que
je suis ici je baisse les bras je laisse
tomber les gens qui m'entourent et qui
m'aime tu devrais y aller
soulever ou
[Musique]
j'ai changé la plupart des meubles de la
maison contre un fauteuil un simili cuir
un petit peu plus à gauche avant cela un
peu vers moi encore un peu et c'est trop
là les émotions doivent sortir d'une
façon ou d'une autre de ma femme ne
laisserait jamais tomber vous lui
remettez à chaque fois way toutes les
semaines ça lui traverse pas l'esprit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est tellement ce trait de caractère
[Musique]
m
je serai plus fort à ses côtés
[Musique]